digging up down
the movie opens with a group of
youngsters clad in prison uniforms
working under the scorching Sun they
appear to be digging holes in the middle
of nowhere while working in such hostile
conditions a young boy named barf bag
purposely gets bitten by a snake to
escape the hard labor the scene then
cuts to a boy named Stanley elnatz
walking in the street suddenly a pair of
sneakers falls on his head and knocks
him down he decides to keep the shoes as
his crazy family is currently working on
a remedy for stinky shoes however on his
way back home he is arrested by the
police on the suspicion of stealing the
shoes it turns out they belong to a
famous basketball player named Clyde
Livingston who had donated them to
charity the police take the boy home and
inform his family about the incident
however the yellnats aren't shocked and
they blame The Misfortune on a family
curse Stanley is then presented to the
court and the judge sentences him to 18
months detention at Camp Green Lake a
juvenile detention center there he is
introduced to the manager Mr Sir Mr Sir
is a very strict individual and he warns
Stanley that there's no point in running
away from the camp because there's no
water for Miles he also talks about the
venomous reptiles of the region which
have apparently killed a lot of people
Stanley is then given his uniform and
told to dig five feet deep and five feet
in diameter every day to uh build
character although he isn't supposed to
look for anything in particular if he
happens to find something interesting he
might earn a day off God I love this
story in the next scene Camp
psychologist Dr pendansky introduces
Stanley to a group of boys who go by the
nicknames x-ray armpit squid zigzag
magnet and zero zero is always silent
because he is the youngest Stanley takes
the place of barf bag in the squad after
he was rushed to the hospital earlier at
lunch when Stanley reveals that he was
wrongly accused of stealing livington's
sneakers zero breaks his silence for the
first time surprising everyone a
flashback then reveals that Stanley's
great-grandfather Stanley had amassed a
fortune in the stock market but one day
he is robbed by a woman named kiss and
Kate Barlow this sends him into a State
of Shock and in a matter of months he
becomes completely broke with no other
choice Stanley the first starts working
at a European Farm where he falls in
love with his master's daughter he seeks
advice from the local fortune teller
Madame zarone on how to win the girl's
heart however zironi tells him that the
girl is foolish so he should immigrate
to the U.S instead Stanley one gives it
a good thought but in the end he
disregards the advice and goes to ask
the girl's hand in marriage
unfortunately the girl's father tells
him to bring a big fat pig as a dowry if
he wishes to stand a chance of marrying
his daughter Stanley the first again
goes to zaroni and she gives him a
piglet telling him to carry it up the
mountain and make it drink water from an
enriching natural stream Stanley the
first agrees and vows to visit zironi
after he succeeds he also promises to
carry the frail old woman up the
mountain so she can regain her strength
and youth eventually the pig grows
bigger in size and Stanley the first
carries it to the girl's father however
as zironi had said the girl turns out to
be very foolish she is now unable to
choose between Stanley and another
average looking Suitor disappointed
Stanley decides to follow zarone's first
advice and sets off for America but in
the process he completely forgets to
keep his promise to her and does not
carry her up the mountain this
infuriates the fortune teller so much
that she curses his entire male lineage
for
eternity back in the present Stanley
grows accustomed to life in the camp one
day he discovers a fossil and shows it
to the counselor Dr pandansky hoping to
secure some time off however the
counselor tells him that the warden
isn't interested in fossils he also
mentions that there used to be a lake
here and all the land around it belonged
to the warden's grandfather the movie
then flashes back again to a hundred
years ago when the warden's grandfather
ruled the town A Man Named Sam is seen
selling onions he has a crush on a local
teacher Catherine so he gives her a sack
of onions for free however in exchange
she gives him a jar of peaches that she
pecked herself in the present Stanley
wins over X-ray and the others and they
accept him into their squad by giving
him the nickname caveman this is because
he is good at finding fossils one
afternoon he receives a letter from his
mother and laughs as he reads her
stories soon zero arrives there and
inquires what he's laughing at admitting
that he can't read he then requests that
Stanley teach him how to read but the
latter declines saying that he gets
exhausted from digging all day one day
Stanley discovers an object resembling a
shell casing with the initials KB
unfortunately x-ray snatches it from him
and gives it to the counselor to get the
day off the counselor then informs the
camp Warden who is revealed to be a
woman about the finding impressed by the
object she reward words X-ray and orders
everyone to dig up his Hull further the
movie again flashes back 100 years in
the past Sam visits miss Catherine and
offers to fix her leaking roof in
exchange for three jars of her spiced
peaches Catherine agrees and over time
the two grow closer to each other
however other men in the town also start
to show interest in her one night a man
named trout Walker hits on her but
Catherine brutally ignores him weeks
pass and Sim eventually completes her
repair work but despite this the two
continue hanging out one day he musters
up the courage to kiss her unfortunately
trout Walker sees this and in a fit of
jealousy he burns down Catherine's
school when the latter finds out about
this she rushes to the local sheriff for
help but even he tries to kiss her he
also tells Catherine that her lover will
soon be executed for the crime of
kissing a white woman terrified she
rushes to warn Sam but it is too late as
he is shot in his own boat this sends
Catherine into a state of shock and so
she decides to avenge her Lover's death
a few days later she kills the sheriff
and finally gives him the kiss before
leaving after this Catherine never looks
back and her journey as an outlaw begins
she goes on to loot wealthy merchants
and landowners before executing them and
bidding them farewell with her signature
kiss this gives her the nickname kissing
Kate Barlow meanwhile after Sam's
execution it never rains in the town and
the lake eventually dries up rendering
trout Walkers land worthless back in the
present one day when Mr Sir brings the
boys water magnet steals a bag of seed
from him unfortunately Mr Sir notices
the missing bag and threatens to punish
everyone when no one steps up Stanley
decides to take the fall to save
everyone else Mr Sir takes him to the
warden hoping to get him punished for
the theft however the unpredictable
Warden scolds Mr Sir instead for
distracting the boy from his digging
when Stanley returns to the field to
zero digs his hole as a way to thank him
for saving everyone moved by the gesture
Stanley offers to teach him how to read
and write as they hang out Stanley puts
two and two together and figures out
that the shell casing you found earlier
was actually a tube of lipstick it
belonged to none other than kiss and
Kate Barlow at the same time zero also
reveals that his real name is Hector
Zeroni it appears that the boy is
related to Madame zarone who cursed the
Yelnats family years ago one day the
manager finds out that Stanley makes
zero dig his holes he berates both of
them for being useless and hearing this
zero becomes so enraged that he smacks
the man with a shovel and runs away from
the camp later the warden and the other
Camp officials discuss Zero's Escape
they predict that he won't survive more
than a week because zero is an orphan it
is revealed that his mother left him in
a park and never came back Stanley
overhears the conversation and it deeply
upsets him later that night he recalls
how his great-grandfather Stanley
yelnatz the first survived 16 days in
the desert after Kate Barlow robbed his
wagon it turns out Stanley the first
survived due to a place called God's
finger no one knows where it is because
Stanley the first had gone crazy when he
was finally found the following day
Stanley decides to run away to rescue
his friend zero after walking for hours
in the desert he finally finds zero
sleeping under an old abandoned boat the
latter reveals that he survived because
of the jars full of peaches he found in
the boat it is evident that the boat
belongs to the late Sam the boys then
notice a mountain in the distance which
looks like a human thumb when Stanley
gazes at it intensely it suddenly Dawns
on him that the mountain is God's finger
hopeful that they might find something
the boys start scaling the mountain but
halfway through zero gets tired and is
unable to move any further refusing to
give up on him Stanley carries zero on
his back and takes him up the mountain
this unknowingly fulfills his
great-grandfather's promise to Madame
zaroni by carrying her great-grandson
once they reach the top of the mountain
they find the creek they also discover
the onions that Sam grew next to the
water meanwhile back home Stanley's
father finally finds a remedy for
stinking shoes a solution of peaches and
onions I can't smell anything Stanley
has also declared innocent and the
family's attorney arrives at the camp to
pick him up however the warden withholds
the information about Stanley's escape
the following day Zero recovers and
confesses that Stanley ended up at the
camp because of him it turns out it was
Zero who unknowingly stole the sneakers
from the charity auction and when he
noticed the police looking for them he
panicked and threw them off a bridge due
to Stanley's bad luck the sneakers
happened to land on top of him hearing
this the latter is taken aback but he is
not upset instead he is grateful as he
managed to find God's Thumb the movie
again flashes back to the past Kate
Barlow finally finds Sims boat in the
dried up lake that is now turned into a
desert as she sits there by herself
remembering her late lover trout Walker
and his wife arrive at the scene they
demand to know where it is hidden all
her stolen Treasures as they are
desperate for money after they lost
everything to the drought Kate refuses
to help them and instead commits The
Unthinkable by letting herself get
bitten by a yellow spotted lizard since
then trout Walker's predecessors
including the current Warden have been
digging through the dried Lake in search
of Kate's treasure back in the present
Stanley and zero returned to the field
to look for the treasure chest where he
originally found Kate's lipstick tube
they eventually succeed but right then
the warden and Mr Sir arrive and try to
seize the trunk however they quickly
back off when they notice that the
yellow spotted lizards have climbed on
to the boys the next morning the warden
is still waiting for the lizards to go
away so that she can steal the chest it
turns out that the boys are alive
because the lizards are averse to the
onions they have been eating after a
while Stanley's attorney also arrives
with the police the warden accuses the
boys of stealing her trunk but her
claims are quickly rebuffed when zero
notices Stanley yellnats written right
on the trunk consequently Stan Stanley
is allowed to leave with the truck while
the warden and her crooks are arrested
it also finally Reigns in the desert for
the first time in a hundred years later
the boys head to Stanley's home where
they share the treasure equally using
the Newfound wealth zero hires a pi to
successfully find his mother and it's
revealed that she too had been looking
for him all this while the movie ends as
the boys become neighbors and invite all
the released Camp kids to visit the duck
might live on the like but my daddy owns
the like owns subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching